Let's go to someone.
Let's go to Yangs supporter from the 9 1 9,
who's Yangs supporter from the 9 1 9.
Does that ring a bell?
Yeah.
Rings a bell for me.
I have a very quick question.
OK.
I just want to know, what did you think of
the last season of Curb Your Enthusiasm?
Didn't see it.
Well, I highly recommend it.
I've heard it and I don't feel like to really.
Yeah.
And also, like, I just looked right next and
I have the right on my bedside table, like,
right as I was on hold.
But I have a book recommendation for you,
which is The End is always near by Dan Carlin.
It came out in October and it like talks about
pandemics.
So a lot of people have been giving it a second
look.
But yeah, it's very good.
Anyway, hope you have a good day.
David Abel, before you go, as as a Yangs supporter,
what are you doing in November?
I'm going to be holding my nose and voting
for Joe.
OK.
I know there's a big debate on the left about
that right now, but I'm gonna be voting for
Joe.
I'm on your side.
Got it.
All right, my friend, thank you so much.
Appreciate the call.
All right.
Thank you.
All right, so we've got so far today, Bernie
Guy is voting for Biden and Yang Guy is voting
for Biden.
Very interesting.